check out this story from 2018. so this
is from geekwire
clash at amazon hq construction workers
shout down council member over plan to
tax big business
so i don't know if you saw this story
but the videos went viral and it was
absolutely hilarious
you had academic leftists wearing their
you know red salute fists
shirts and shakers shirts yeah and they
were like we want to tax this and we
want to regulate this
and a bunch of guys in yellow vests and
hard hats
were shouting them down protesting so
these academic
lefty types keep saying over and over
again we represent labor and the working
class
they don't they're the academic
intelligentsia these
they represent college kids who've never
had a job
and these middle middle-aged dudes who
work construction who are actual labor
showed up and protested them oh that's
what we needle it was in seattle we need
to see more of this
so uh let me let me read a little bit
they say that so this is 2018
we have this video the clash at uh i
think it's outside of amazon
headquarters they
say council member hashama sawant asked
reporters to join her in front of
amazon's iconic spheres
as she implored her colleagues not to
back down on the so-called head attacks
despite amazon's announcement that it
will pause some of its growth plans
pending the council's decision
but sawant struggled to get her message
across as dozens of seattle iron workers
nice drowned her out with chance of no
head tax
yeah i don't see these lefty you know
black lives matter types anthony types
they're they're not labor they're not
unions they're not workers
right the unions are i i my
understanding is that many of them split
for trump
there's a big shift yeah definitely the
the worker bees of the unions that's
that's very red i think very working but
the people who run the
you know the depart the chamber of
commerce and the department of labor
so yeah i mean i think that's just
another reason why they have to have
these narratives come in
um of you know racial inequality because
if all the workers like kind of woke up
and realized they were being screwed by
the same permanent class
they'd they would have a huge problem so
so right now
in this country and it's been this way
for years you have
upper class academic intelligentsia
white-collar workers claiming to
represent labor
right they don't but it is it is
fascinating because
if you look back at history when when a
lot of the philosophy and a lot of the
the ideologies were being written and
conceived of
like marx for instance there there
wasn't
like new classes have emerged the middle
class you know it
emerged at some point upper middle class
upper lower class lower middle class
upper lower whatever
so you started to see all of a sudden
regular people now becoming landlords
they weren't typically lords but now
there's like an expansion of different
classes and what happens is you and you
end up with people who are
fairly well off relative to everybody
else but they're not super wealthy
so they view themselves as labor well i
work for this big company i work for
this billionaire therefore i'm not upper
class i am labor
but they make twice as much or three
times as much as the guys who actually
build buildings and
farm the crops right and now they're
protesting as though they
are the the suffering you know working
class but they're actually like
they're they're mid-level bourgeoisie
yep and most of them to get that job
they had to
go to college and that's where the
indoctrination started so i think we
could chip away at a lot of this too by
waiving a lot of the college degree
requirements especially like in
government if i get into office i want
to
start hiring people that don't have
college degrees i want to waive the
requirement that
to work on my staff you have to have
university yeah that's that's actually
that's been a big trend over the past 10
years actually it's been it's been you
know
growing and growing uh as i just stated
moments ago and you know a little in a
previous
bit i don't i don't care for college
degrees you know
if you have one if you don't it's
meaningless to me yeah you show me your
portfolio show me your passion show me
you can do the job and you want to do it
and i'm down and we can work together
and we can make some
cool stuff happen but when i get people
like here's my resume i went to college
for this i'm like that means
nothing to me right yeah like i do i
used to hang out at colleges you know
what i saw
i saw people going to school for like
music production just drunk all day just
right yeah just partying and drinking
and i'm like and then i i i know some 16
year old kid
who was every day producing and making
music and working with bands and i'm
like and he knows 100 times more than
that kid went to college yeah so your
degree i'm sorry your piece of paper is
great and all but
it means nothing to me in fact i'll tell
you this college degrees
in my opinion detriment you know why
people with college debt require higher
salaries that's right
and if the company can't afford it
you're going to lose out to the
competition who can do the job and
doesn't have the degree
but it's the perfect means of control
like you have the ideological test there
within college and people get really
good following instructions then they're
saddled up all this debt
so they can't they have to go live in
the pod and eat the bugs because they
can't afford a house out in the country
they have to go
live in this city they can't afford to
have kids make families
you know it's it's a genius way to
control i i i really
am not a fan of uh you know people
saying like i have no choice i have to
do it
i think about the people who got on
boats and just you know just landed on
the shores of nothing yeah
let's start building yeah imagine that
like first ship that came from europe to
the united states it's hard to look
lucky enough to meet in some
circumstances like you know with the
story of the first thanksgiving
yeah okay we're starving it's winter and
the native americans like we're gonna
help you out yeah and then there's a lot
of bad history there
for sure right but i but outside of that
there were people who said
i'm gonna get a boat for three months
you know one in five people will die
on this journey right literally just in
the ocean before we even get anywhere
and then once we get there nothing there
we're gonna do it now you have people
who are like
i should be able to have a house the
houses exist give it to me yeah exactly
so so even people who you know they get
degrees and like i have no choice i have
to go move to the city it's like
have you considered just living the way
humans have lived like why why do you
feel entitled to
all of the luxuries of life right i i i
think about this
you know uh when i saw the i was on the
williamsburg bridge in new york
free to use for everybody somebody paid
for it
somebody built it but you just get it
for free that's the kind of thing that
people don't understand
they don't realize how much work and
suffering and sacrifice
was done for them so that they can have
all of these free things yeah
now they're entitled to now they demand
it my attitude's always been like dude
if i
if i was in the middle of the woods and
i was buck naked that's that's zero
that's like that's where i'm like okay i
got nothing i better get to work
yeah if i was you know if i had a pointy
stick hey i'm up
one like i got stuff this is good pointy
six great yeah no but
we're way beyond that we live in luxury
we've got clean drinking water we've got
hot water
even even even our homeless in this
country are overweight yeah yeah
it's actually a problem we should get
them better food they're eating bad food
but you know
we're we're almost a victim of our own
success we definitely are
now people are trapped in this
entitlement mentality instead of
realizing what life is and
that you're entitled to nothing so how
do we get out of that you know how do we
get people back to the
chopping the tree down you know just to
get the wood for the winter to
heat their homes to be responsible for
themselves and not demand all this stuff
from cities from governments yeah i
think we have a lot of work to do
with messaging like the more work that
you do and the more independent you are
the more that you actually have your
freedom like you
we need to shift the culture from like
hey you you have all these things that
are entitled to you
like you by the time you're 30 years old
you should have a house you're like well
no not really like you should work hard
enough to get a house you should have
the
the means to pursue life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness that's what well
that's what's so great about this
country but that doesn't mean anything's
guaranteed
now this is where i'm well i think many
on the left and the right will probably
agree
well i should say many of the left were
paying attention it used to be a lot
easier to buy a house
it did the house is the housing market
wasn't as crazy but you know the issue
is
federal reserve the system we have where
joe biden is able to just snap his
fingers and
flood the market with money yep strips
everyone's ability it hyperinflates
yeah it strangles the market and so it
is getting harder and harder to buy that
house
yeah my attitude is you know man i'm not
going to be demanding of anyone else
i'm responsible for myself and now if i
have to go live in a cardboard box
because that's what i haven't had access
to like well you know what no one's got
to build anything for me
right so i'll go into the middle of the
woods and i'll hike into the mountains
and i'll figure something out i'll live
in a bus in alaska if i have to you know
beaten down
but it is an issue if our society can't
function because people can't buy houses
because
the market's been just absolutely
manipulated and broken
yep and then i'm not surprised we're
headed towards you know some kind of
crisis yeah we just had so much
individual agency taken away from us by
the federal government you know for
varying reasons but the
but the end state has been total control
like the fed's a great example
so i think we just need to get that
rugged sense of what it means to be an
independent american
back i think there's cultural work to do
there but i think really expressing to
the american people the
the economic crisis that we're about to
be in because all these different
countries right now could chip away at
our economy china could pull out the rug
from right underneath us so
we i think if we got back on a wartime
footing to getting our production back
online i think we could potentially see
a shift it might take as much of it as a
as a generation for people to understand
that like hey you're not entitled to
anything but you can go work hard
well let's let's think about this joe
biden's got a six trillion dollar
spending package and a lot of it
includes repairing bridges and you know
roads and infrastructure like what what
are your thoughts on that
well the if if it was just truly
infrastructure i'd be okay with that but
his infrastructure bill is like six
trillion and
he considers everything it's like child
care is infrastructure and like all
these different programs or
infrastructure like he just
if he says infrastructure then he gets
to spend money on it it just doesn't
work that way so
there's infrastructure work to be done
for sure but like what when you go and
you repair a road or a bridge like that
takes concrete that takes steel so let's
produce that here in america like why
why don't we have steel and concrete
factories getting back online if we need
to repair the
infrastructure it almost sounds like
it's on purpose
you know so here's a few of the problems
they say they want to increase the
corporate tax
the corporation's got to pay their fair
share yep then they say also
we've got to pay everybody a higher wage
also
free trade no tariffs on imported goods
exactly
then china says they complete the puzzle
they say no taxation here
cheap labor with no human rights and
when you put those things together what
do you get
a corporation says okay so it's going to
cost us an extra 10 million for salaries
it's going to cost us an extra 10
million in corporate tax
and we'll save 20 million by putting our
factory in china
yeah but a factor in china right we can
ship the goods in for free it's
incentivizing it
now you look at joe biden's
infrastructure plan and yes like you
know childcare's infrastructure was the
meme
at the same time as he's trying to
rebuild infrastructure which
some of it is a good thing he's also
still in uh pushing the unemployment
and now the child tax credit which is
going to give up to like three thousand
dollars per family
yeah which just gives people money so
they don't need to work which means
if you give a bunch of people money they
don't work you're not going to hi find
people in the united states who are
going to want to produce the steel
or the concrete right and the quarries
they're going to be i'm good
and then the only option is for those
companies that are getting contracted by
the federal government biden steps in
and says
i got a billion dollars to build this
bridge so we're going to need you know x
amount of steel x amount of concrete
the company is going to say wish we
could find somebody to do it but nobody
wants to work
i guess we'll buy from china yup and
it's once again incentivizing sending
our infrastructure
our capabilities to china yep and then
who do they have do the labor i mean joe
biden just
opened up our southern border so we have
we have then here comes the illegal
immigrants for the handful of
working-class americans that do want to
work
why are you going to hire working-class
americans you got to pay their health
care you got to pay a minimum wage
i you know you can just go hire a couple
illegal immigrants and
save a whole bunch of money and then
whenever you're done with them you can
pretty much discard them so
they're being gutted yeah we're
absolutely being gutted yeah another um
i guess you would call it uh a danger
with our
regarding our sovereignty is the the way
that we get paid
the way that our money system works like
right now you work 40 hours for a
company
and then you trust that they're going to
give you the money for it
you make youtube videos and then you're
going to trust that when youtube says
we're going to pay you that ad revenue
that it's going to arrive but you still
have to trust that the company's gonna
send you the money
you trust that paypal is gonna take that
money and send it to you sometimes they
don't
i know and so we're on the precipice of
smart a smart contract economy where the
money just
automatically goes there's no middleman
that holds it and sends it yeah
that's a that's a big that's a big
danger how cool would it be
you know with with the crypto markets
you didn't get paid
a week after you work or 30 days like if
your contractor
you're you're literally just watching
the crypto trickle into
your account every minute you work your
your your account
if the taxes were paid instantly i mean
that would be so and they could be
that's another thing too like you know
we got a bungled up tax system
we do the the irs knows what we owe
they could literally just deduct and
like have a nice day they play a
guessing game you know well you know uh
what they say is that these big tax
preparation companies
are have incentivized not to end the
system so
yeah they lobby to keep the machine
going and it just wastes everybody
everybody's time and energy
for the sake of the economy to keep the
machine going hey if they want to do a
great reset can we start with resetting
the temperatures
yeah seriously because a lot of these
taxes don't make sense oh what a
what a breath of relief that would be
for people to have that stuff taken care
of
i think crypto is is going to be awesome
but so uh
you have you followed bitcoin and all
that stuff i have a little bit yeah so i
think you know bitcoin is the one
true key these other cryptos are i'm not
one of these doom sayers a lot of people
hate what they're called altcoins like
ethereum these other companies
now i'm a big fan i think the technology
is fantastic max kaiser got in your
brand
what kaiser got kaiser campaign i just
agree with you you know max cos
he loves he came over he's like bitcoin
all the way but yeah i just agree with
him you do
yeah max is saying all of the
alternative coins are bad uh i
don't agree with that i i don't think so
i think bitcoin's fantastic it's
decentralized
and i think if we were operating on that
system or or some kind of standard with
that
you can't get a fed to come in and pump
money and devalue the system you got
bitcoin your bitcoin's good
because it's a decentralized system no
one controls would you would you say
that bitcoin is
backed by the us dollar or like bitcoin
completely
replacing the dollar uh i i don't think
it replaces the dollar yeah i think it
holds value and they call it digital
gold
right so it's not necessarily something
you're going to be using every day for
spent for for
buying stuff however uh max said once
it's around half a million to
between like half a million per bitcoin
like a million dollars per bitcoin
then you'll probably that's what it
stabilizes when it's like you know above
gold or whatever
uh bitcoins is a store of value it's
almost like it's a bank account
yeah so a lot of these companies track
your bitcoin in dollar value
yeah and it goes up all the time now the
recent crash
people who are inexperienced with
bitcoin are freaking out but people who
have been using bitcoin for a long time
don't know don't care yeah because
if you're holding bitcoin you're going
you're you're not losing value if you're
holding dollars you're losing value oh
yeah
so that's why i think bitcoin is truly
going to be incredible
there's some issues with it it's fully
trackable it's extremely transparent oh
yeah kind of a bad way
but i look at this as maybe that is a
way to fix
a lot of these problems they're not
going to be able to pump money into the
market if people lose confidence a
dollar and they switch to a
cryptocurrency market
you've got smart contracts people get
can get paid on time there's more trust
in the system
however the only way that can happen is
if confidence in the dollar is lost
which would be
some kind of
yeah and then people switch over it
would be funny if it becomes dogecoin
yeah it just becomes like some some big
standard yeah i i don't know though i'm
i'm confident
and if i were to make a bet not giving
anybody advice
i wouldn't be surprised if in 10 15
years we were on a bitcoin standard of
some sort
if you look at the trends like the
banking transit that makes a lot of
sense
yeah ceos of jp morgan other yeah
fully on on board i think as long as we
controlled that and then we actually
were a production-based independent
country
that wouldn't be a huge deal i think if
china goes and says like hey the u.s
dollar is so worthless
you guys need to buy into whatever china
coin or some form of
chinese bitcoin like that could be a
major problem for the entire world and
i'm sure that's what china
i mean absolutely again with with the
way that we're running up our debt like
they could do something like that fairly
easily
that's what's scary yeah if uh if we
don't do this right
and i and and i think we're not
no china china could absolutely create a
centralized coin and then
replace the reserve currency and say we
only do business in china coin that's
the smartest way to fight us really i
mean thucydides trap of like us going
and duking out and shooting with china
like i i don't think that's necessarily
going to happen
but if i were china i would just
continue to
uh purchase our debt so we gained the
confidence that that's always going to
be there we keep printing money
they keep watching us eat ourselves
alive of critical race theory and racial
tensions
and then at the time of your choosing
you choose to pull out and stop buying
our debt
yep i thought about this a long time ago
you know
like years ago maybe like a decade ago i
started my friend and i was like man
what if chyna just one day said yo we're
not going to make your stuff anymore
yeah we would just instantly be like cut
off from everything we'd be sitting here
hold an empty bag and i was like man
what if they said that and then declared
war
right we're totally screwed yeah so i
guess we can just fire
the missiles but right then what yeah
exactly
maybe maybe that's intentional because
you know they say that uh
it prevents war right they want these
free trade agreements so that we can't
go to war because the u.s is too
dependent upon china
no it sounds to me like when you look at
what's going on with international trade
china's been exempt from everything
they talk about climate change and
reducing carbon emissions how often do
they mention china right
and china says we're not going to do
that that's for the rest of you guys to
beat each other up with
they build new new coal power plants
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you